I heard that you also sing and I was
just curious like what's your go-to
karaoke song alright I will so gives you
our singer know you want to even speak
your voice is like whoa I don't say I
can carry a tune yes you can sing go to
karaoke would probably be like Jon Bon
Jovi I'm a cowboy for the old sir
mix-a-lot classic baby got back you can
sing especially no cuz people really
want you to sing like I've heared some
random carry it apart nearly I'm not
gonna do for real I mean like rappers
and maybe horrible like it's that's
funny
what is yours what's your go to any
things I'm like Eminem jay-z like
anything I definitely shouldn't be
singing yeah everyone expects me to get
up there and do like you know ballads or
whatever and I'm like that'll look like
a tool I do my all-time favorite we
actually just had Rick Ross on azulon I
love the whole rap are you seeing like
crazy it's weird that I know the whole
you need to go care I want to see blow
your way to beat I will blow your mama
can't wait I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this